- Everybody, it is time to
crack open our show vault
and share something we've
never shown before today.
Earlier this year, Hollywood power couple,
Nick Offerman and Megan Mullally
dialed in from separate
rooms of the same house.
That's a real true thing.
Megan and I got to talking
about how we got started in music
and she shared some
pretty revealing things
so check it out.
I feel like all people,
like, no matter what part
of the industry you're in,
we all started like musical theater,
like when we were kids
and doing stuff like-
Did you do that?
Did you start like musical
theater when you're young?
- [Megan] I did, I used to
sing, my parents would go out
and I'd put on Barbara Streisand
and Judy Garland records.
- [Host] Yes.
- [Megan] 'Cause apparently
my parents were a gay male couple, ch.
(laughs)
(slaps thighs)
And I would just like sing
one song over and over again
until I could sing it
exactly like the record.
And then first time I sang
in public, I was a senior
in high school and I went to
this apisca paleon school,
private school, we had chapel every day,
which is so bizarre and embarrassing.
And so I was encouraged
by the people who like,
did such things to get up in
front of the entire high school
and belt out three show
tunes, which I did.
And I was incredibly nervous
and it ended up going well,
but I had choreographed a song
from the musical, Chicago,
called, Razzle Dazzle.
- [Host] Yeah.
- [Megan] And during it,
I went over and sat on
the principal's lap,
which was like a huge, crazy
thing to do at the time.
And then Nick and I were just
in Oklahoma City recently,
and we actually found the
cassette tape of me singing
that.
- [Host] What?
- Which is-
- [Megan] Yeah, it was crazy.
- That is so cool.
- [Megan] Yeah.
- I randomly, I think
it was my mom that said,
oh my God, I randomly found
a VHS of like me doing
something like in high school.
And I was like, what?
That's what-
And I'm the same as you, I used
to memorize stuff like that.
Like I would sing Don't Rain On My Parade.
Like I sang it so much.
I wanted to sing it again.
- That the first song
I sang, wait, that's the first
- [Host] Oh.
song I sang in chapel.
- That's my favorite.
Literally when I was at
Radio City Music Hall
(coughs)
and we were on tour
and I cover songs all
the time, I was like,
I will cover this song
(claps)
in this place
and it will be magical.
(claps)
I love her so much.
- [Megan] Oh my god.
- [Host] No, that's a great.
- [Megan] That's (indistinct)
The first I sang was
Don't Rain On My Parade.
Then I sang People.
- [Host] Okay.
- [Megan] And then Razzle
Dazzle from Chicago,
but they're all not razzle-dazzle as much,
but Don't Rain On My Parade, and People
are really hard songs to sing, you know,
for your first time
- [Host] Yes.
It's like Weird and Grieve.
- [Megan] singing in public.
- [Host] And Don't Rain On My Parade.
I also secretly love that
you kind of gave your, either
teacher or principal, a lap dance and
(laughs)
it was kind of amazing.
- [Megan] (indistinct) really dazed,
I mean the word lap dance
(laughs)
(claps)
hadn't been invented.
- See, he invented rap and
you invented lap dances.
You are the perfect couple.
[Crowd] Woo.